My guest this week is
the award winning Nigerian
writer and author,
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie.
Named by Time Magazine as one of its
most influential people.
Her writing covers everything
from war to feminism,
to most recently, a very
personal take on grief,
having lost both of her
parents in quick succession.
I want to ask her about being described
as fearless, for speaking her mind,
and also what it was like to team up
with Beyonce to try and promote feminism.
Chimamanda welcome.
It's so lovely to have you
with me on this program,
and see you in person.
I know.
Thank you Emma,
for having me.
It's lovely to see you.
Well, the last time we
spoke, was last year.
And, you had just penned
a short book called
Notes on Grief.
And, we were talking in
a difficult time for you,
but you wanted to talk
about losing your father
and then losing your mother.
And, you said to me you were
trying to understand grief
and process it.
And, I wonder,
I wanted to start by
asking how you are today.
Well, I think I'm learning that a lot
of living is sort of
pretending to be fine.
So, I think I'm doing that very well.
Yeah, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Thank you for asking.
But, I think everything
happy that happens to me now
is always tainted by a kind of,
sort of like a residual sadness.
And, it's because I just adored my parents
and it still feels very,
very disorienting for me.
I bet
I mean, you talked about
those stages as well,
you know, coming undone, feeling unmoored,
but, you are right about
the world expects you
to get back to some place.
And, you have your
responsibilities as well.
And, you do, you just sort of,
but, you carry something with you always.
And, I, it's interesting because I thought
that I would be more aware
of this kind of emptiness
in my life when I'm sad.
But, actually it's when I'm
happy, it's when I'm having
a lovely day and suddenly I think, my God,
I can't FaceTime daddy.
And, I had thing in the US last month
where I got a lovely medal,
and I love those things,
cause I just love shiny things,
and I really did want to take my phone
and FaceTime my parents,
because, that's what
I've done my whole life
when I've been given something meaningful.
You know, it's to call my parents.
Well, they're the people who cheer you up.
So, I really, I mean,
I really was going to FaceTime them
and thought, wait, I can't.
And, so, it's those moments
that are really just painful.
Something else you said,
which has stayed with me,
is the idea that we live in this world,
and we know death's a part of it,
and we're still so surprised.
It's incredible.
And, even when we see, as I do now,
life is short, you really need
to think about what matters
and how you want to live.
It's also at the same time a
strange thing to live life,
always thinking about death,
because, in a way, death is
sort of, it's the unlife,
it's the not life.
And, so, it's a strange thing I think.
I think a lot changed for me
when my parents died,
in the way that I think about
life and how I want to live.
But, I think death is
still surprising, too.
It still is.
One of the ways,
I dunno how much this speaks to you,
but, people talk about faith,
and that helping them
through these sorts of times.
Do you have that in your life?
Have you come back to that?
It's very complicated.
After my father died, I
started, I was raised Catholic.
Yes, I'm Catholic, well, raised Catholic.
There's a difference I think for me,
between being Catholic
and being raised Catholic.
One doesn't have a choice and one,
the other, you kind of have a choice.
And, I started going to mass,
because, I found it soothing,
but, particularly, because
it was what my father did.
My father was just this
lovely faithful Catholic.
But, then I had trouble with
the Catholic Church in Nigeria,
and I was so angry, that I stopped going.
And, it's a long story, but,
I'll just say very briefly,
that when my mother died,
at my mother's funeral,
a priest used the opportunity
of my mother's funeral
to attack me about an
interview I had given.
And, so, imagine just sitting there
just being completely lost,
because, you still do not
understand what happened.
Your mother's gone, and my
mother died so suddenly,
and a priest at her funeral
takes the microphone
and says, Chimamanda
was attacking the church
because she says the church
is too obsessed with money,
which they are, which I said,
but, at my mother's funeral, you know.
So, that made me so angry.
And, I haven't been back since.
Did you say anything at the time?
Or were you...
Oh, I did.
I got up and I said,
I need to speak because,
you cannot do this.
And, I then I did spend a
lot of time seeking redress,
writing to bishops and, nothing.
I think how religious institutions
use their power over individuals,
but, also how it intersects with politics,
is in people's minds,
especially in America,
at the moment, since Roe v Wade,
with the overturning of that ruling.
And, I wanted to ask you about it because,
we see in Christianity with Christianity,
it being used by
politicians, by legislators,
to defend the rowing back
of those particular rights for women.
And, you of course are very
well known for speaking out
about feminism and the rights of women.
You know, someone raised Catholic,
how do you look at that,
and that situation?
Well, the first thing I think
is that one should never
impose one's religious views
on anyone in democracy.
And, I've often felt quite
respectful of those people
who for religious reasons do not support,
or want to have abortions.
I think that's fantastic for them.
Right?
But, to somehow insist that
a woman doesn't have a right
to do what she wants with her body,
and, to then justify that using religion,
I think it's just completely
unacceptable for democracy.
Just, it makes no sense to me.
I mean, for me, being Catholic
doesn't mean it's sort of
agreeing with everything.
Even when I was a child growing up,
I was a bit of a, I think
at Catholicism classes,
I think that they were irritated with me
because, I would sort of poke holes
at some of the things
that we were being taught.
If collectively as a society
we really believe that women are equal,
we would not be having this conversation.
If you step back and think about it,
it's actually almost surreal to say,
your body doesn't belong to you,
is a very strange thing, I think.
A lot of people describe you
as fearless now.
in this age that we live in,
where social media was meant
to liberate us and allow us to share.
But, in fact has imprisoned us, I think.
And, there's a real
concern, in particular,
that women are being pushed
out of the public square,
not saying what they really think.
Do you have that concern?
For myself, no.
For women, yes.
You know, when I'm called
fearless, I guess it's nice,
but, I don't really think
of myself as fearless.
This is what I've always been, really.
I think part of the reason
I'm so fiercely feminist
about the way I look at the world,
is that, I knew from a very young age
that to be a girl and to be as I was,
which was sort of
outspoken, asking questions,
was kind of seen as odd.
So, even now, I think,
as sort of an ostensibly full-grown woman,
to be told, you really say what you think.
It's a thing that's a compliment
for women, not for men.
But, I think we're also living in times
where to say what you think...
Yes, that's true.
...has also become something
that people are called fearless for.
Yes, yes, that's true.
Which again, to use
your word from earlier,
has a surrealism to it.
I know it's only one platform,
but it is the platform
a lot of the time of debate
in terms of social media
with Twitter now being run
by Elon Musk, some people,
men and women, have left
the platform in process.
Equally, others are saying,
now there will be, or could be,
real freedom of speech.
Do you have a view on that?
I don't think one person
should be in control of a platform
that has that kind of
outsized social influence.
I just don't think it makes sense.
And, you know, people can say,
Oh, well he bought it, it's his,
or before they would say,
Oh, they're just really beholden
to only their shareholders.
But, I think it's a public utility.
We should think of it as a public utility.
So, it really shouldn't be one person.
This is the way we live now, sadly.
And, we have to figure out a way to,
I'm going to sound like a a
preacher, we need to do better.
But, I really think we do.
I don't think we can change,
I think we can change
how we use the platforms.
I really detest this kind of piling on
that happens when people
have said something
that somebody doesn't like.
And, you know, it's not just
that you criticize them,
it's that you publicize their address,
you put their children's schools
online, that sort of thing.
And, you try to get
them to lose their jobs.
I have just never felt
that that is in any way
a reasonable response to bad speech.
Right?
But, I also sometimes
wonder why there isn't more
that's done to those
who pile on on people.
So, so often we'll say,
Oh, that's terrible.
But, that's it.
I mean, I'm not on Twitter,
but, I think if I were, and
there's a reason I'm not,
it just would not go well,
because, I think I would go after
the people who pile on people and be like,
you're just a piece of,
and you need to stop.
I mean, you have had people,
even though you're not on that platform,
be very upset about various things...
Oh, yeah.
...that you've said.
And, has that affected you?
Yes and no.
I think, so in general, I think this idea
that we're supposed to
say that we're fine,
when you hear that the tons
of people maligning you, publicly,
to say that I'm fine would be to lie.
And, I think it's either you're lying
or you're a narcissist.
Because, how can you
not be affected by it?
And, so, the first time that
I heard oh, they're saying
that you are terrible, and
that you're a murderer,
I was just deeply hurt.
I was deeply, deeply hurt.
What was that after?
Was that after something you'd said, or?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, surely, I mean,
I didn't kill anyone.
Yeah, I know, it's good
to check, in interviews.
There are some people
I would like to kill.
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
So, it was very hurtful,
but, it won't make me change.
It will not make me
change how I live my life.
It hasn't and it won't.
I'm still going to say what I think.
So, you don't, you haven't self censored,
because, that's the real
risk here, isn't it?
When we get into this position.
Because, I did notice you have not wanted
to answer questions about
when you said in an
interview, for instance,
trans women are women,
and not necessarily to go
into that issue per se,
but, I wonder why you haven't
wanted to talk about that.
No, what I haven't
wanted to do is say more,
but, I've said what I said,
and that's what I think.
And, why not say more?
Because of the reaction?
Or you said...
Well, because it's been
said, I just think...
Complete?
Yeah.
Because I just think also that
this is sort of this age of,
like a friend of mine said,
you said what you said,
anybody asking you more about this
is just trying to stoke outrage
and make it more of a thing.
And, which was never my intention, right.
I said what I said, it's what I believe,
it's what I still believe.
But, then having people say to me,
tell me more, tell me more.
I'm just like, no.
And, also, you know, I have a full life.
There're many, many
things I'm interested in.
And, yeah.
And, I suppose, when people have thought
about that particular
issue and gender and sex.
There's a lot of talk
now about J. K. Rowling
and how she's continued to share views
and be very alive on
platforms, such as Twitter,
to this particular topic.
But, there's now a bit more
of people in the public
eye who've worked with her,
coming forward to say exactly
about freedom of speech.
Then why has she been treated in this way?
Why has there been this?
And, I wonder if things
are changing or turning.
I don't know what your take is.
I dunno, have you ever
spoken to her about this?
No, no, no.
I haven't spoken to her.
But, so, when I started reading
about how she was being attacked,
I then went and read what she'd written,
which I thought was perfectly reasonable.
And, I did not see why
she needed to be attacked.
And, I think that she's
been treated abominably.
And, I think a lot of that treatment
is because she's a woman.
I think that a man who aired his views,
reasonable views, would
not be treated in that way.
And, there is also something
I think very dangerous
about refusing to engage
with what she said,
but, instead making it,
instead of hurling insults.
But I read, I remember
reading what she'd written
and underlining bits, because...
This is the essay on sex and gender.
Yeah.
... underlining bits of it,
because, some young
people in Lagos had said,
Oh, she's terrible, she's transphobic,
she wants to kill trans people.
And, so, I said to them,
where does it say that here?
And, I don't even mean a literal sense,
because, there are ways
that you can read something
to mean something else,
but, none of them could
point it out to me.
And, I suppose this goes
to one of the essays you wrote, called,
It's Obscene.
You talk about cancel culture
and lots of other things in there.
But, you do express this
concern, this particular quote,
you say, "we have a
generation of young people
on social media so terrified
of having the wrong opinions
that they've robbed
themselves of the opportunity
to think, and to learn, and to grow."
You talk to young
people, you lecture them.
I saw recently, you told them
to get offline for three weeks
and read some books.
But, it's a serious issue.
And, I know you're
probably thinking about it
as well as a parent, but
what can we do about this?
Whew, we can try being adults.
I sometimes feel as
though we have abdicated
our responsibility as the grownups,
because, I know what it
was like to be young.
I thought I knew everything.
Now, I look back, I'm
like, I knew nothing.
I was wrong in many of my
sort of fierce positions.
And, I was fortunate
that when I was young,
there were adults who
were willing to tell me,
you're actually really
not right about that.
Here's what you should
think about differently.
That's not happening now.
We're also not saying to young people,
you cannot, I mean,
so, I remember talking to students
at a university in the US,
and it really made me sad,
because, well, first of all,
we meet and I'm asking them questions,
and it felt as though they
were repeating party lines
in a way, about just general issues.
I think it's tough for them.
And, I just, you know,
so, I did a little preaching, and I said,
can we all agree on compassion?
Can we all agree that
not everyone means harm?
Can we all agree that people
can learn and people change?
You know, just sort of basic things
that we seem to have forgotten, I think.
There are lots of things I don't know.
I mean, there're things
that I don't understand.
And, again, not to go back to the famous
A trans woman is a trans woman.
I thought I was saying something obvious.
I did not mean to offend anyone.
And, later I thought, wait,
what have I missed,
things I don't understand.
So, I went back and I
started reading things,
because, I just thought I
really didn't understand
what the noise was about.
And, so, I think about
young people and I think,
I'm sure there are many
people in my position,
which is to say, do
not know the orthodoxy.
Right.
And, who should be given
a chance to know it
and then choose whether
to accept it or reject it?
I don't think that they're
giving that chance.
Yeah, well, and also, they don't feel
they have the space necessarily,
to have those conversations.
A lot of people want to hear, I suppose,
where your feminism is up to.
And, I wonder, because,
feminism in that time
is less of a dirty word.
Certainly in the Western world,
it's being sold as a brand.
It's by fashion, by the media.
But, I wonder if it has
achieved what it's meant
to have achieved, yet?
No, of course not.
It's not going to achieve
it in the next 100 years.
It took a long time for us to get here.
We've had, really, human
history, the sort of,
the length of time that
we've been here on earth,
we've had men be in charge.
And, if we're going to achieve equality,
it's going to take a long time,
so, that it doesn't,
I think for me,
maybe, the question I
would be interested in is,
are we taking a few steps forward?
But, at the same time
we're seeing marching,
we're seeing protests,
and since the death of
Mahsa Amini in Iran,
who was held by Iran's morality police
for not covering her hair properly.
She died on the 16th of September.
Those protests are carrying
on, led by women in Iran.
And, also, in Afghanistan,
women trying to go back to university,
or their jobs, since
the Taliban took over.
It's very striking.
There's a footage going of a few women
being whipped by Taliban...
Oh, I saw that this morning.
...outside of the University.
But, chanting, Women, Life, Freedom,
which is the same words
chosen by women in Iran.
And, while it's awful what's being denied,
there's also something
in what's being said.
Oh, I find it enormously inspiring.
I think that they are just absolute stars.
Particularly the women
in Iran and Afghanistan.
Because, you think about what
they're standing up against.
And, I felt that that the whipping video
is such a dramatic example of,
of what their lives are like.
But, they're still pushing back.
I just find it so inspiring.
And, the women in Iran when
they're cutting their hair
and they're throwing
the thing in the fire.
I actually was weeping
watching one of the videos.
It was incredibly emotional to say.
And, also, it's happening, now.
You know, to get your
head around that as well.
I always wondered if
you found it frustrating
that some came to your
work through Beyonce,
as opposed to finding you themselves?
No, I'll tell you one of the reasons
that I was happy to
do, happy to say yes...
This is because she,
just to say if people dunno,
she took some of your words,
sampled some of your words for a song.
Yes.
About feminism.
It's because I thought
that she has such a huge following
that there are going to be people
who never heard the word feminism,
never thought about it,
who will because of this.
And, for me, that's a wonderful thing.
But, to have people come
to my readings and say,
Oh, I never heard about you,
then I heard you on Beyonce,
and then they don't want to
ask me anything about my books.
they want to ask me, so Beyonce,
that doesn't interest me very much.
It doesn't work for you.
That's not the way this is gonna work.
No, but, I think also
there's a part of me that just,
I feel this way about films as well.
When people say,
Oh, it's fantastic, your
book was made into a film.
And, I'm thinking it's nice,
but, I wrote the bloody book.
I want to talk about books.
I want books to be cool.
I want be excited about books,
you know, and we're just not.
And, it just, I just feel
deeply, deeply annoyed by that.
But, it's, you know,
whether we have the wrong heroes and
how we look at the world
and implement things for us.
I do, I agree.
And, also what the responsibility
that those heroes have,
and I'm wary of talking about this
because, I do not like people telling me,
you're a role model therefore
you should not do this.
But, I think for example,
that Beyonce making the decision,
and people can think what they will
about talking about feminism,
I think it's a really good thing.
Because, and I know for a fact
that there are many young people, who,
because of that, suddenly,
I know relatives,
young nieces, who, auntie
talks about feminism.
Auntie writes books, Beyonce
They're like, I'm a feminist.
And, now, they're making what they think
are feminist arguments.
And, I think it's fantastic because,
conversations are happening when...
It's good to hear that Beyonce
helped you get closer to your family.
No, among a certain sort of cohort,
the family, they suddenly thought,
Hmm, auntie's not too bad.
She's okay.
She's, you know, we can, Yeah.
She's tolerable now.
What are you working on now?
I cannot tell you.
You can't tell me,
you don't like saying it, do you?
Until it's done, okay.
But, writing, I imagine.
Or? Okay.
The creativity though, has it
come back since your daughter?
Is it coming?
It's slowly coming back.
But, I think again,
that's amazing for women in particular
to be able to hear you say that.
Because, again, it's not something
that's talked about, a long after effect.
Yes, yes.
I think it's really
important to talk about.
And, also to talk about
it, knowing that we love
that we had the gift of
motherhood and babies,
and we adored them.
Such a gift if you want it.
It really is, it really is.
But, you know, we should
talk about the other things
because, nobody told me about the,
I had horrible joint pains, my fingers,
and nobody told me about the constipation.
And, I just feel like we need
to talk about these things.
And, you laugh at, when
I say constipation,
which apparently, is the
puzzling response I get
from other people as well.
No, we should talk about,
I personally was shocked
and I was like, what's happening?
And, my husband is a
doctor, and he was sort of,
Oh, you didn't know.
And, I wanted to punch his face.
I was like, Of course I didn't know.
Well, there's two types
of constipation here.
There's the literal and the creative.
Of course.
So, we've covered both.
I like that actually, fantastic.
Chimamanda, thank you very
much for talking to me
and to all of us today.
It's been a pleasure
and memorable as always.
Thank you Emma.
And, thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.